apple says that the 13 pro max has a
dramatically more powerful camera system
and that it's their biggest upgrade ever
but is it really that much better than
the 12 pro max and the 11 pro max that
came before it well today we will find
out the truth with an in-depth look at
everything from colors and detail
dynamic range to the new three times
lens the new macro mode video quality
night mode shots and much more and let
me tell you this thing isn't always the
best in some cases even the 11 pro max
actually takes the win now with that i
will also give all those of you guys
that bought a 13 pro max or the 13 pro
some very helpful tips on how to make
your images look better than they do
from just shooting there's a couple
things that are very important so with
that let's go ahead and jump right in
now starting out here you can see that
the images look almost identical between
the three phones and this is a situation
where you really won't notice a
difference you have bright good lighting
but as we move on you can start to see
that there is a difference in colors and
contrast with both standard shots and
ultra wide shots you could tell that
apple has been increasing that contrast
level year over a year now it still
looks good it's not too contrasty but it
does have more pop i personally like the
increased contrast especially in shots
like these this is an ultra wide shot
here where that shadow really makes the
shot and it really sets the mood instead
of being really flat like the 12 pro max
i pushed hdr just way too much now the
next thing that you could tell is a
difference in white balance and this is
consistent the 13 pro max i noticed was
noticeably more consistent with its
white balance and consistently warmer as
well you could tell going from the 11
pro max moving forward here with the
sunset that sky does look much more
pleasant looking warmer than before and
when it got darker it actually holds the
mood kind of the shadowing more so it
looks more like what i actually saw with
my eyes in this last sunset shot the 11
pro max and 12 max look almost identical
and they're just brought up a little bit
too much with the hdr whereas the 13 has
that nice reflection on the hood
finishing off with white balance you
could see that the 11 pro max was
constantly more cool
even with different lenses it just looks
too cool the dash does not look that
color and now let's jump into detail do
the 13 pro max's photos have more detail
or what most people would call sharpness
well it is a mixed bag let's start out
with that new three times lens and as
you guys could see as we're zooming and
switching to that and here
i ended up zooming in all the way the 13
pro max's image looks way better in
every single way not only is it closer
we have 10x compared to 12 and then 15
on the 13 pro max but it has a lot more
detail and a lot less noise in the sky
which was an issue that was plaguing
iphones for a long time now when you
zoom out when you're just using a
standard 3x compared to the two and a
half and three the differences aren't as
apparent uh but at further diff
distances you do notice a little bit
more detail and then it's up to you if
you like that crop having more zoom by
default in this next shot i zoomed in to
10x on all three phones because that's
the max that the 11 pro can do and you
see a massive amount of differences the
12 pro and 11 pro looks soft kind of
waxy whereas the 13 pro max it has a lot
of detail it almost looks like it could
be from a dslr shot and with that it has
better dynamic range as well so that's a
big improvement same thing goes for this
shot right here 10x on all of them and
the 13 pro max looks nice and clean good
contrast and much more detail on the
trees in the back along with the sign
here's an example of what that 3x zoom
gives you compared to two and a half and
two and then what the maximum zoom gives
you in a tough dynamic range situation
as you can see none of these look great
but the 13 pro max definitely wins
without all of the noise and issues with
the 11 per max you especially see it on
that one now you might not always want
to zoom in that much 3x is a big jump
compared to 2xb4 you might want to be
somewhere in the middle so i tested it
this way where i set it to 2x that means
that both the 12 for max and 13 pro max
had to do a digital crop from the main
1x sensor it actually doesn't look that
much worse the 11 per max is slightly
better because it is using a telephoto
lens instead of cropping in but the
difference is negligible now this is
going to get interesting once we get
into the night mode shots you guys don't
want to miss that switching over to
detail with that main lens you guys
could see that there's pretty much no
difference when i crop in five times
into a photo they look almost identical
and here's the full size just to show
you how much i crop so other than the
contrast and kind of white balance
differences we don't actually get any
more detail from that lens and if we
compare the ultra wide lens this is
where we do actually have a big
improvement the 11 pro max looks pretty
bad 12 per max got better but the 13 pro
max is clearly the best dynamic range is
better and we get more detail all around
here's what that shot looked like
originally so that is a good crop so
thankfully apple upgraded that lens as
well now there is one lens the apple did
not change and that is the selfie camera
it's the same 12 megapixel sensor and
what about the detail well if we take a
look it is actually slightly better but
that is because of their software and
the new a15 chip we have slightly more
detail and of course the warmer white
balance that we get all around now let's
go ahead and jump into dynamic range
this is where we have a massive upgrade
as you could see the 11 pro max is
blowing out a bit of the sky uh the 12
for max tries getting more dynamic range
to give you a brighter shot and the
faces look better but look at the sky
it's actually even worse on the side of
my face but the 13 pro max it is more
detailed a lot more dynamic range we
also have more contrast at the same time
it is a much bigger difference and look
at this guys
that is a massive difference right there
i'm shooting against that sunset the
images for the other two older phones
look terrible 13 pro max actually has
slightly less detail because of that
dynamic range but that is the shot you
want look at that sky in that sunset
right there jumping inside and switching
to the standard lens it's not a huge
deal but the 13 pro max kind of combines
the other two photos in terms of
contrast and dynamic range overall it
does look the best and the same thing
goes for these next two examples
slightly better dynamic range and better
contrast leading to an overall better
photo and you can clearly see it in this
last shot look how faded the other two
are just because they're trying to
maximize the dynamic range smart hdr4
can do the same dynamic range but we
retain that contrast which looks great
you can definitely see it in this shot
as well look at the sky look at the
ambience of that sunset that is kept
compared to the other two which you
either choose you know maybe some
dynamic range or you choose better
contrast so you have less compromise and
one thing you may notice especially with
the center shot the 12 pro max is the
flaring this was a big issue with the 12
pro max that we talked about and apple
has done a great job take a look at this
next shot this is with the selfie we
have really bad flaring on the 11 pro
max definitely some and some contrast
loss on the 12 pro max 13 pro max is
definitely better and then switching to
the rear lens look at that line on that
12 for max from the little circle bump
um the little ring that's around the
camera that is completely gone on the 13
pro max and it has a little bit less
flaring than the 11 pro max and then
switching back to the front facing
camera shooting against the sun the
flaring on the other two are they're
pretty bad there with the contrast stuff
like that
i made sure that all these lenses were
clean every time i took a photo i took
those multiple times on the other
cameras and it's incredible what apple
has done to minimize that with this new
phone i know they shifted the camera to
the other side they could be using
better flocking material to remove some
of that light balance but the image
looks so much nicer and now let's jump
into portrait mode at least here in the
daytime and as you guys can see we have
some big differences we were just
talking about flaring you could
definitely see the difference here 13
pro max even though that 3x lens has a
lot less flaring because of that has
more contrast and you'll also notice a
difference in zoom ranges between 2x 2.5
and 3. so we have more compression which
is what real photographers want they
want to use lenses that have more zoom
so the background is kind of
disappearing there so the image
definitely looks better with the 13 pro
max but with the standard lens in most
lightings the difference is very very
minimal now i also noticed a few things
that really surprised me when i took
some portrait shots something that i was
not really expecting so let's take a
look at this image as you can see both
the 11 pro max and 13 pro max were able
to take the shot with portrait mode but
the 12 wasn't able to do that so with
the 12 telephoto lens you can't get as
far away and you know have it still work
so that was actually a complaint i had
with that 12 pro max we complained about
that lens i liked it less than the 2.5 x
lens but with this new 13 pro i really
like this 3x lens but there is a
downside
with shooting a subject like this this
is with the standard
lens the wide lens if you're taking a
photo of a static object like this
side by side here both the 13 pro max
and the 12 pro max were not able to take
the image i was too far away if i was
going to get any closer i would crop out
the sides it might be something to do
with lidar on the newer phones i'm not
exactly sure but this was a consistent
result taking a look at some more static
objects the 13 pro max definitely has
the best edge detection it is improved
the 11 pro max really messed up this
shot there was you know random airplanes
showing up with stuff blurred around
them the little stripe there whereas we
just have better results with this lidar
if you're closer to a subject the same
thing goes with the fountain the 13 per
max just has better edge detection even
better than the 12 and looking at the
sign right here the edges are really
nice the depth mapping looks good
dynamic range is better less flaring the
shot's better in every single way and
then switching to that 3x portrait
telephoto lens it also looks nice having
that extra compression in the back and
the edge detection is also slightly
better and now let's cover macro
photography where we have a few very
interesting findings and i have a big
tip for you guys starting off with this
image this is using the 3x lens and then
the two and a half and the two i just
want to point out that compression how
much nicer is it to have that background
disappear instead of seeing more of it
especially with the 11 pro max getting
as close as possible the 12 pro max
looks the worst but it's the 11 pro that
actually takes the win with a more
detailed image now this didn't really
make sense to me so i kept taking even
more photos and i found the result to be
consistent with that telephoto lens you
not only could get closer with the 11
pro max it's also more detailed as well
of course with the 13 pros we have that
macro mode that switches to the ultra
wide and allows you to get super close
to your subject which is very cool to
have but it's up to you if you like that
perspective and if you need to get that
close personally i prefer the photo on
the 11 pro in this case now this is an
example of another time where i used it
but i didn't feel like the image looked
any better especially compared to the 11
pro max once again that is just really
detailed when you are close up with that
telephoto lens so then i tried to just
switch over to the three times lens and
i got this image which looks pretty dang
bad it looks worse than both the other
two a lot less detail more noise looks
kind of waxy so what i actually figured
out when taking this is that the 13 pro
and the 13 pro max it switches to the
ultra ride way too early and in order to
stop that you can actually put your
finger over that ultra wide lens and it
will stay with the telephoto and it will
give you this result that looks much
better than it's switching to that macro
mode
still not as good as the 11 pro max that
one looks the best but still a very nice
pleasing image and now let's get into
night mode where things are gonna get
very interesting starting out with
indoor lighting where you have some
light it's not pure dark here with the
standard lens porsche shot these look
almost identical one thing that i
noticed is that compared to outside
where shots got warmer with the 13 pros
inside with night mode they actually get
cooler than the others and it does look
good but as far as detail i'm not seeing
much of a difference and then with the
ultra wide you've really noticed that
the the iphone 13 they're starting to
get darker shots they're trying to keep
that booty kind of feel and the white
balance is cooler now you notice the 11
pro max image looks like garbage that is
because it did not have night mode with
the ultrawide lens that was a big
limitation switching over to the
telephotos the 13 max looks great in
this lighting it's closer we have more
compression more detail less noise the
image is better than the 12 for max
which is better than the 11 pro max and
now what about when things get really
dark well here's a shot where we have a
big difference with the portrait shot
here where 11 pro max looks quite a bit
worse we have night mode with the toy
pro max looks better and the 13 pro max
you actually start seeing a difference
in these really dark scenarios flipping
over to the selfie camera once again we
have a big difference the 11 pro max
can't do night mode selfies and the 13
pro max the weird thing what apple did
this year is that the night mode ends up
staying on much longer in this case i
think it's about three seconds and it
gives you more detail a more natural
more pleasing looking image
it's a lot better and now when we switch
to that 3x lens when it's really dark
it does not look that good one thing
you'll notice the portrait mode doesn't
even work but the image is more noisy
it's just weird not a lot of detail
it looks bad now here's another trick
for you guys if you're using this mode
and it tells you that you can't take the
portrait make sure to get out of it
because this is what we get when we get
out of portrait and go to night mode now
the 13 pro max looks brighter more
detailed it almost looks like a daytime
shot so apple will actually keep you in
that portrait mode shot even if it's not
going to take a portrait if you if it's
too dark and the image looks bad here's
another nighttime selfie in really dark
lighting and the iphone actually stayed
open for seven seconds compared to just
three for the 12 for max and then 11
doesn't have that that image looks like
it's daytime look at the detail there
the lighting is much more flattering was
the 12 pro max actually looks like it
flashes on because it flashes the screen
much brighter for that three second
exposure and now for extreme low light
shots we have another selfie all of them
look terrible
but the 13 pro max it's really cool too
cool in this situation 11 pro max you
can't really even see me switching to
the standard lens the shots look amazing
this is the same exact location where
it's pretty much pitch dark now you
don't really see a difference in terms
of uh detail in the image and that is
because night mode allows you to stack
those images they have computational
photography and i took another shot in
similar very dark lighting and you can
tell that the 13 pro max's lens and
sensor are much better so this is
without night mode the len pro max looks
terrible 12 gets better 13 actually
looks somewhat decent and as soon as you
turn on the night mode capability the
results look very similar in terms of
detail now what i really noticed is that
there is a difference in terms of
contrast and then the white balance that
i mentioned earlier you see that the
whole scene looks a lot more moody and
then with the ultra wide you really see
that instead of looking more like day it
keeps the image a lot darker which you
might like or maybe you don't now even
though the 13 pro does have more
contrast you still actually get more
detail look at the 11 pro where all that
is just crushed there you also notice
this in these shots where you have more
contrast you have more shadow detail it
just looks better overall and then both
of these have less flaring with the 13
pro max and now let's switch to the
ultrawide lens in night mode here you
guys can see a difference year over year
we have a brighter image that is more
moody more contrast and it's more
detailed as well the 11 pro max even
this well-lit situation looks much worse
and this shot right here is on a tripod
obviously 11 pro max no night mode 13
pro max definitely looks sharper there's
less motion blur on the moving trees and
the 12 pro looks brighter overall now
some people have mentioned that with the
13 pro it is darker you have to move
that slider to make the shutter stay
open longer so i did that to both and if
you do that the 12 for max still ends up
being brighter that's just how apple is
programming these cameras overall the
ultra wide lens is a big improvement
with the 13 pro max but now let's switch
to the telephoto and as you guys could
see we are closer we have less noise we
have more detail it is a better shot and
then this one you guys could see if i
zoom into 10x on all three cameras which
is the maximum for the 11 pro the
difference is massive in terms of detail
we can actually focus there we have just
a better shot in every single way it
doesn't even need explanation but here
we have something that's a little bit
different now
with this uh 13 pro max the telephoto
lens is a f 2.8 meaning it doesn't let
in as much light so it has to keep the
shutter open so you're going to be
holding that phone longer for night mode
shots and here you just get more motion
blur on the actual trees and because of
that some other shots like this one
actually look worse on the 13 pro max
than they do on the 12 max or the 11 now
the 12 pro max in the 11 they'll
actually switch the 1x lens the standard
lens and crop in digitally whereas the
13 will stick with the actual telephoto
and the result is actually worse so this
is another pro tip for you guys if
you're shooting with a 3x lens without
zooming in even more so what you need to
do is zoom out slightly so right here i
matched up all of them at 2x you can
even go to 2.9x instead of 3 and then
the 13 pro max switches to the standard
lens with the crop it looks much better
and now instead of looking worse than
the other two it looks better so
definitely keep that in mind and now
let's switch to video and in a lot of
normal situations we actually don't see
much difference at all the colors are
fairly similar it's a little bit better
for flaring because it may be better
coatings
or flocking or i'm not sure what else
they did but it's pretty close now in
terms of dynamic range it is just ever
so slightly better if you look at that
plant in the windowsill we also have a
little bit more contrast at the same
time stabilization looks almost
identical and if you're shooting in the
dark as far as noise it is just slightly
better with the front-facing camera uh
just because of the newer processing and
then here you could see that the new
lens placement or maybe other changes
results in less flaring like the 12 pro
max has and less contrast loss if you're
shooting against the sky so definitely a
good improvement there now switching to
the standard lens as far as detail you
can't really see much difference at all
even in terms of dynamic range they all
look really similar switching to the
telephoto you guys could see how much
closer that 3x lens gets but in video we
don't really have that same difference
in terms of quality like we do in photo
mode and for the last new feature with
the 13 pro we have cinematic mode here
you guys can see the difference
unfortunately it does drop to 1080p and
in tough situations
it is really hard to get a good edge
detection there but if we switch to the
front and you have a person as a subject
you see that it actually does a really
good job and the dynamic range is
actually better for some reason as well
maybe because it's 1080p now what i
would say is that for the cinematic mode
i wouldn't have crazy expectations if
you're shooting people running outside
in different subjects in b-roll but if
you're shooting youtube videos like i am
right now this could be an excellent
tool if you have a subject a fairly
plain background a tripod to really
replace a camera and have a microphone
and camera system that could give you
some blur and even for editing you could
do on your phone so it's gonna be a
great tool for people that are getting
into youtube videos and things like that
and as far as low light video we really
don't see that much of improvement
compared to 12 pro max even though we
have a brighter lens just slightly less
noise but compared to the 11 pro max the
result is much much better so what do
you guys think is the 13 pro max really
that big of an improvement in the areas
that you care about let me know down in
the comment section below overall i
think this is definitely a really big
improvement not in every area but most
areas have either slight improvements or
some pretty massive ones especially in
things like flaring some of the dynamic
range especially with that selfie camera
that is a huge upgrade and the new modes
are really nice to have as well but i
want to hear your guys's opinion go
ahead and click that circle above if you
guys want to see our ultimate review on
this phone check out one of those great
videos right over there maybe the
comparison against the s21 ultra if you
haven't seen it this has been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]